[Musique]
il est difficile de se promener sur la
place de l'indépendance de kiev sans
s'arrêter ici s'arrêter et penser à ce
que s'est passé il ya cinq ans quand des
tireurs embusqués ont ouvert le feu sur
les milliers de manifestants cent quatre
sont morts pour stopper la dérive
autoritaire de l'ukraine vers la russe
volodia chaplin ce cas était père de
famille il s'était fabriqué cette armure
avec le couvercle d'une vieille machine
à laver explique sa femme vous êtes la
nation race témoigne rocard qui restera
quand même cinq ans plus tard le simple
fait de tenir son armure me fait sentir
son énergie
volodia est un héros en ukraine ou même
titre qu'un soldat cette médaille
svetlana l'a reçu en mains propres du
président petro porochenko mais elle a
du mal à la regarder
on me tire avec les dasri échec à cet
engouement très difficile d'accepter
qu'il ait donné sa vie pour que notre
pays change a resigné le choc la révolte
de la maidana a bel et bien changé le
cours de l'histoire de l'ukraine
il arrivait de prochain au pouvoir ou le
maiden n'était que le début pour moi je
savais que la guerre suivrait dit peter
qui a joint les forces armées prêt à
mourir s'il le faut pour tenir tête aux
séparatistes soutenus par moscou de
rossi
peter est un miraculé il a marché sur
une mine dans un village que sa brigade
a réussi à récupérer des séparatistes un
sacrifice certainement dit et met ses
convictions n'ont pas changé
si nous nous étions pas battu c'est tout
le territoire ukrainien qui serait sous
occupation russe aujourd'hui il votera
sans hésitation pour son commandant en
chef le président petro pour le chêne co
qui a fait de la menace russe
le principal enjeu de cette élection je
crois que le choix de zéro ce qui est
beaucoup plus modéré sans être un agent
de poutine maxime usine est un analyste
populaire à la télévision
ici ils voient ans volodimir et lenski
une option moins toxiques il n'est pas
aux fanatiques nationaliste que c'est
déjà bien
comment se comportera le vainqueur avec
la russie est une question qui hante
beaucoup d'électeurs dans cette pizzeria
de kiev qui devenu un lieu de
prédilection pour les jeunes vétérans de
la guerre ou dubaï et elle est
convaincue que s'il était en vie son
mari serait lui aussi à la guerre de
gouvernance radio craignant de voir
cette jeunesse ukrainienne plus
patriotique qu'elle ne l'a jamais été
mais elle ne croit pas qu'elle votera
pour porochenko cette fois car pour elle
le patriotisme c'est aussi paris sur la
paix et la stabilité
ici tu as marre altérer ce que
radio-canada kiev